all right Pitbull
what kind of what kind of name is
Pitbull for a female
it's vicious young it
I'm I'm as Loyals it could be I can
protective or I could just basically
bite bark and lock
that's how you got the name
pretty much I was always a friend Center
you only like when the homies are
sitting there taking forever you know
like something's popping off I'm always
the one that's right there
where'd you grow up I grew up in
Wilmington
the heart of the harbor probably Long
Beach no Wilmington where's that uh it's
in the middle of Long Beach and San
Pedro Harbor City
like all like Carson all that but it's
just right in the middle
tell me about your family
well my family I was raised with my
grandparents you know my mom
it's hard to get over there you know she
basically gave me up when I was two
so I was raised with them you know I was
raised with my grandma and grandpa and
my aunties my uncle
you know but maybe my cousins what's
your mom give you up at two
I guess as good as mines you know I mean
that's why I got a tattoo mom never
loved me that's how I felt that's how I
seen it
how would you describe your childhood
oh what was all right
it's okay
it was always wishing like because I
didn't mean my dad's house 18. so and he
was just in the city next over you know
so it was
I mean like I it was pretty good you
know I mean like I was a good kid you
know I was in cheerleading Pop Warner
you know football like all that little
good stuff you know and then until
basically like I seen a different I mean
I was around the gangs I seen all the
homies grew up with the homies and [__]
like that but like never got really too
involved in it until like I seen like
certain things and they excited me you
know and I've seen how the way the
Loyalty well at that time I seen her
loyalty and how Survivor was and how the
way they protected each other you know
and I wanted a piece of that because I
wasn't getting that at home
he's like that was your family
pretty much
pretty much I mean I'm from West Side we
must I'm from the wall Park not the
projects but the wall you know so like
just blocked down from where I grew up
and just you joined the game pretty much
yeah as soon as I graduated from
elementary
right there kicking in the wall she's
chilling you're a blood or a [__]
neither one but I'm sure to the blue you
know but like you know what
the the Mexican games are a lot more
different from how the way like
losing Christian you know you're a
Mexican gay
what does the gang life do for you I
mean at the time like you showed me like
showing me love he showed me like like
they showed me how I feel to be like
like with the family you know like like
now I just feel neglected not how to
feel like
just like left behind but then later on
as soon as I started growing up I think
started changing a little bit more you
know
people started separating became enemies
or or just you keep with the good ones
and you keep with the bad ones or
whatever it is but you grow in with the
experience you know but it's
it's not what it it it shows me at that
moment time when I was little
did you feel rejected by your appearance
oh yeah I did yeah I didn't actually be
born you know
because you tell me like I respect my
dad because everybody did me him like he
told me straight up you know like
I didn't want you
you mean I told you Molly when you do
the supper is you but what can we do
you're here you know like you're here
and I'm like yeah
I'm here right you know and
like what's up Dad you know or can I
call you that or but the only reason why
is because he wanted to stop the child
support because my mom was collecting
you know but like I said she lived a
good life with with my stepdad and the
kids
my brother and sisters
and do you have children
yeah I got four of them but I made a
promise to myself I wouldn't but like I
said
I wasn't supposed to have kids you know
also I I wanted to live in in the hood
live it breathe it you know what I mean
that's all I knew was straight like
neighborhood
you know just like Robbie people jumping
out on people you know I mean like like
running up on anybody you know because
it was a thrill it was adrenaline
you know breaking into cars you know
coming up or however it was you know
like I mean but there's also the bad too
you know I'm gonna speak hard but like
the pros and the cons but like
nightmares you got to live with
you know like there's love you gotta
live with you you learn things I said I
was raised by
I was raised by by thugs schooled by
Killers but I only listened to the wise
you can't believe everything everyone
says
you know I mean like people sell dreams
like a [__] you only sell to you
if you want to buy them
do you have regrets in your life
I try not to but I do
I really do I regret not like
being there more for my kids
but
showing what you love the most the sight
of weakness out there
you can't show that
because then you're easy target
and I'll be damned if anyone goes after
like what I care for and what I love the
most so I'd rather I'd rather live it in
silence than just stay away and it hurts
because like I miss my kids I got three
baby daddies and I'm all the first baby
mama you know
but like
my real best friend was
my first baby dad I was a homie lover
friend
and just recently like a couple years
ago like he passed away and that was the
hardest thing I had to do was tell my
daughter I heard that passed away you
know from
uh I guess the fatty and stabbing heroin
y'all
I feel like that I left him behind you
that was one of my regrets that I lived
like not being there like how I always
was that was me sure I never turned my
back
another day I did
that drugs is part of your life
yeah they are
I don't before I used to blame I should
try to blame someone you know I mean
like but then I realized like there's no
one to blame on myself I choose to get
high I want to get high I want to numb
my feelings I don't want to feel
and that's the only reason why I say
denying because I do not want to feel
the pain
of neglect
rejection
just the pain I don't want to feel it
did you feel love is it as a child
no I'm from a certain extent you know
and it's funny you bring that up because
like
someone the other day was like
no you're mean you're you're mean uh you
weren't hugged as a kid huh you weren't
hugged as a child I said what the [__]
you say
he's like oh you want loved on a child
you weren't hugged
this food literally had enough balls to
say it again so he said he was like oh
you weren't loved as a kid so I turned
around I said black I popped him like
busted his [__] mouth open and put
like put hands on him you know what I
mean and was like don't you ever taught
me that [__] you know what I mean like
you don't know [__] you don't know
nothing you know and I shouldn't have
did that actually just laughed about it
but it actually hit a point like where I
was like [__]
like am I really mean like that because
like was it loved
like I see things
with shoulder things
I mean you're not proud of them
but it's like
how do you go about things you know I
mean like I don't know how to be a girl
my mom wasn't there
in
my daughter like my Aunt did a pretty
good job of my daughter
she's a beautiful little girl
graduated from high school not into
games
no boyfriends because I always put that
in her hair like
how do you feel about boys and she's
Batman they're a distraction mom look at
you he's like yeah you better shut up
you know but
she stood into like like social media
and positive things you know
motivational things
but I'm like she's gonna be a good kid
and I tell my son now my sons
those are those are
two individuals right there I mean those
are Martinez Brothers
that's for my marriage because I wasn't
I did get married you know like I was
married for quite a few times
and those are my son that's just my
son's performance for my for my first
marriage but
kind of sucks when you really love
somebody and you gotta let them go for
certain reasons you know
and it's like
it's [__] up
because it's like I I really did like
thought we were gonna be something and
be and have a happy little family you
know what I mean but I guess it didn't
work out like that he chose to do what
he did and
and I hate to say you know I mean like
he pc'd up so I had to let him go like
you can't be with a [__] but he's not a
[__] you know he's with the program
he's with the business like he's
you know take care of you guys take care
of but
I could I I mean personally I can't walk
with anybody with my head down you know
like I am who I am I am made I made who
I am you know I don't fall underneath
nobody's name I don't follow no family
like I got family from hoods yes
but like I want to make sure my name was
mining and no one could sit there and
take my name because that's my name
and it's like it's [__] up because
it's like
I missed out of my kids growing up
because I chose that getting life
and it's not the drugs that take me out
every single time
it's my lifestyle I love the thrill of
the lifestyle I love being out there in
the hood I love being like like just the
thrill of it just it makes like
it gives me chills you know what I mean
it brings excitement you know because
sometimes like
there's other individuals who ain't
being schooled right
and if I got if I'm put in their path
they [__] I put in their past you
know what I mean like my grandma used to
tell me like
your last name is Rango you know I mean
like well after R you're an angel you're
either gonna bring them to the light
you're gonna bring them to the dark
but you are that little [__] dark
goddess you are that little dark little
[__] princess you know what I mean
but like you're a good you're a good
person
which
you can be evil when you want to be evil
but it's like
it sucks
because sometimes I do want to live a
good life
how do you go about a good life
when your childhood was half and half
all I remember is just every time I went
to my mom's house
and because I didn't get proper
permission
and I said I used to be like
take her back
take her back if I spent the night I'd
be left
early morning and my grandparents house
and they wouldn't be up yet but I'm left
at the doorstep
and I'm like damn
my all the money that my dad was
shooting for for child support or
whatever like that
they're living in love go to Disneyland
places you know I mean like music Parks
enjoying life but what about me
what about me
so everybody else's mom was my mom
and it's like and it sucks
[Music]
like I got my two aunties
those rewardians
and I respected the [__] out of there
and I love them like to the fullest and
I would do anything for them
but what
what the
the main one who who looked out who went
to every court date
every busy
still solid
getting money even though I even asked
for it you know because I always feel
like you guys are taking care of my kids
you know you know you gotta taking care
of my kids I don't need nothing
but then I know how to survive
and what's the odds of
going to go gamble because she loves she
loves the gambling I mean like my family
loved it you know
and on the way coming home
she gets hit by a drunk driver
next time's on the spot
and I'm like damn that's what they told
me I didn't believe it
they still don't believe it
I'm gonna hear prior to that
because I still know I still don't even
want to know about my little baby cousin
was murdered
it's a shot in the face supposedly or
whatever
The Story Goes you know what I mean I
know because if I would have known I
would have been on I would have been
snatch it up on the streets she was a
good kid
and they sit there and they think like
how come I how come I'm a survivor
all right I'm not part of the [__] I've
done
[__]
sometimes things gotta be done out the
way they gotta be done you know but it's
like it's [__] up
because I'm a girl you know
I'm supposed to be doing girl [__] I'm
supposed to be like getting ready
wearing high heels you know what I mean
like trying to look cute and everything
like that you know I'm trying to get
that boy's attention but I'm too busy
out there like running up on people like
well how much you owe me how much [__]
it's almost shot you know
and it's like
can a person like me really be loved
can I allow someone to really love me
can I enjoy your life the way I want to
enjoy it
can I be that mother to my kids like
like or is it too late
I got a baby daddy my last one who
swears he a gangster but yeah you want
to call the cops on me because I busted
the windows out and I want to beat his
bitch's [__] what the [__] you don't
mean like [__] disrespecting my kid
that's what we always arrangement I
won't ever give you no problems it could
be whatever you want to just make sure
that they know who the [__] I am let
them know that I'm baby mama you know
what I mean ain't no disrespect no [__]
and don't try to be no parent we
straight
but it's just like
I'm like a ping pong where it's just it
goes all over there
and it's like where does it all boil
down to you know what I mean
maybe if I was loved as a child could I
have been on my deeper because I had
things I was already graduated in high
school but I wanted to go to the Marines
but nope fell in love with someone that
who was who was good to me didn't cheat
on me but it was very abusive
diet and
very abusive
but he loved me in the most sickest way
and in my head I thought that was love I
was too scared to be with him but it's
too scared of evil
so I still with him
until until his last dying breast when
he ELD twice
brought him back the first time I got my
ass whoops and then
he did it again not strong afterwards in
couldn't run back didn't even know
what's going on nobody hear me out no
one wanted to listen to me when I kept
saying to take him to the hospital
when you taught me a good investor in
life was the rose without a Thor and was
racing without no trust but stay [__]
without no building a foundation a bond
communication because if you can't talk
to me then I can't talk to you and if we
can't talk then what's a sense of even
trying to be with each other you know I
mean like
talk I talk back
but it's like I'm so
I get so scared to allow any individual
to get close to me
because I
everything that I love the most
let go
and it says
because you don't want to lose
everything in life but you lose
and you feel like you keep losing and
losing and losing this is like
you're just trying to take a a breath
it I take one step after another step
and why do you keep getting knocked the
[__] back
okay let's not talk about haters
because it's just like damn like like I
said I'm not even a Playboy model I am
who I am you know what I mean I try to
be the best individual that I can be you
know because that's all I can do
I don't go it with bad intentions to go
hurt people I don't go away oh I'm gonna
take this from this one this that from
that one but if you take for me I'm
taking everything you got in this
you mean I love that's the love of
thrill that I get I don't I'm not gonna
steal your [__] behind your back I'm
gonna I'm gonna take it from you in your
face because I want to see what you
gonna do about it
and it's like it's [__] up
because you get constantly accused of
Randomness [__]
but it's just like just step up to the
plate just tap into my face and that's
how you feel then let's do this other
than that
I'd rather just make money get high and
just try to live life the best way I can
so that I I can have that chance to go
back to my kids
I like at least that's one thing I want
to try is to be a mom at least once
see the difference between me and my mom
my mom left me
I still try with mines
and even though they they keep me away
but at least I try
I guess all I can do is just either pray
for a change of heart or
pray for something
but
I got good demons and I got bad demons
you know what I mean My Demons play well
with others it's not my fault they can't
play well with me you know what I mean
it's just like
that's why each day I would I wake up to
where I go to sleep or even on a quick
night out you know what I mean I wake up
and I'll stay able to smile on my face
because I'm not gonna let no one know
that I have pain just for what so they
can feed on it try to figure it out hell
no I'd rather just laugh at them and
treat it like a feather in the wind keep
on letting it flow
so they can't take it they can't take
this white cider yeah I don't know now
like measuring those companies you're
not sure the [__] ain't gonna be that
Comfort again if you try to be that
company you ain't gonna last long so I'm
very hard to maintain you know what I
mean I'm a very hard I like to sit there
run around jump around with music
my soul
because even though they took the three
main individuals out of my life which is
my grandmother
my auntie my cousin
at least I try
every day to make it better for them
try to make it I try to make my kids
proud
they could be a load but it sucks it
alone
because I I went on a tick tock and I
see the thing with my daughter
where uh it was a um a thing talking
about like she was doing like one of
those video things or whatever and it
was like her talking to my cousin my
cousin's trying to tell her
to forgive like to forgive me learn how
to forgive me
and she was like hell no I'm never
forgiving
she left us
and I'm gonna get my head like I never
left you guys
you guys turned your back on me
but it never left to I love my kids you
know they may not see me but I'm up and
down those blocks making sure that
they're protected making sure that
they're fine making sure that ain't
nobody gonna go [__] with that Bop
because I will do life for my kids
that's one thing for sure
I will hurt whoever hurts my kid
this is like
that's all I got you know all that helps
me breathe every single day
and one day I prayed
that he could have that opportunity to
sit there and and
getting back when I lost
I'm not mad at the Devil you know he was
just giving me Temptations to play with
I'm not mad at the father upstairs
neither because he was just giving me
lessons to learn
so I was like what I want to do in
between when I'm walking am I going to
learn am I going to prosper or am I
going to fall back and be a little [__]
what's going to make you stronger what's
gonna make me weaker
and I'll be damned if I give any of
those haters
any any type of glitch out or any type
of like
Amusement of knowing that that I'm
falling
because hell no
I'm gonna make sure that I survive every
single day
what would you say is your greatest
strength
she's knowing that that I made it
throughout the day throughout because
for me
each day is not the same [__]
different day it's different [__]
different day with some of the new
adventure are you willing to Route are
you willing to ride with me with it
because it's going to be an adventure
so each day is it my greatest
my greatest accomplishment is just
knowing that I survived for the next day
do you get an adrenaline rush from the
street oh yeah I do that's that I had I
had a person tell me one day he was like
because I have the time I'm not even
high I just like that that quick little
thrill that quick little like that as
soon as the back of the hair my neck
stands up like oh yeah it's on you know
what I mean it's just like oh I get the
chills and it's like I get off on that
I get off on that a lot more because I'd
rather have a focus individual mind if
I'm gonna go do something or anything
like that you know I don't have to be on
drugs I don't need no pump up I am who I
am the only difference is I go faster
that's it
I was the only difference the other day
I'm the same person on one as well as
off one
what do you see for your future what do
you want to be in five years
probably better than where I'm in right
now
I mean it
I see myself prospering a little bit
more better if I try a little bit more
and not let negativity or let
non-motivational individuals
bring me down then I could actually get
that
I just need to believe in myself a
little more
but I don't think anyone on the streets
is getting ahead
they're all just surviving
and now they're always being crying
they're all just being slithering snakes
it's a snake bit hey hell yeah and I
just sit there and look at all them I'm
just like man
I watch Every Step I Take and I pay
attention I just don't jump into certain
things because
I'm not gonna be the one diving into a
shallow end
where do you stay are you oh I right now
I reside in Long Beach but you're Bob
from Wilmington yeah I so I go back and
forth but you have an apartment a motel
um surviving in the streets I'm
everywhere you're just wherever
I could sit there because it's a
privilege when someone opens up their
door to me I don't mean I don't take it
for granted I don't bite the hand that
feeds me I can't I can't afford to lose
I can't afford to burn any Bridges or
nothing like that do you think you're
living this life because this is what
you think you deserve
um sometimes
sometimes
your friends
I got acquaintances but I do got a good
handful of friends I can say there are
two friends
in karma
no certain certain teams
Karma will come no mean if you allowed
to
me that's why I try like anything I do
like I try to uh be careful on how I go
about things at least now before I
didn't I could care less like whatever
you want to do come with it you know I
mean I still got that mentality but at
the same time I'm just like I'm more
careful
I'm not gonna have anything fall back or
either I mean because it's a cold evil
world out there
but what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
they like a man so you'll get played
like a [__]
that's a good one
all right Pitbull thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you thank you
for you know me as an audience and
apparently just to sit there speak a
little bit you know me because sometimes
it's hard to sit there and voice out
anything you don't get to talk like this
on the street do you um
so I mean if I could sit there and help
someone one day then hey it is what it
is at least they got something to me
all right thank you very much you're
welcome